Because there is only a limited time, but it
is important to me that we express that
we are a bilingual community and that
Spanish is very important to me, to
our community.
They're repeating what I just said.
A family if he is your cousin.
to the personal ones, our
superintendent who is here
today.  We're going to make some announcements.
Our Juan has some
refreshments for you.  As you know,
we have help for the children out there.
If they have to leave, so be it
.  They don't have any.  There's a
bathroom back here quickly before we
begin.
First, why are we sitting like this?
And something important about Montessori is that
we have children of many ages together,
but they respect the age we have for each
one.
Ah, this is the interpretation of the
circle, so it's difficult to put a
single circle.  Our administrator
helped me.  What would that look like?  Miss Alison,
the librarian, also helped me,
and Mr. also helped us with setting up the
screens.  This gives us a place where
we can see each other,
hear each other,
and we are all on the same level.
The second part is a celebration, a
very diverse community.  We have families
from different countries and states who speak
different languages, with different
skills and abilities and different
incomes. We have people who are new to
Montessori, some who have been with
Montessori for decades, some who chose this school,
and people who live around here
and crossed the street and may not be
so concerned about
Montessori. But that means that in
other communities that can speak with
one voice, it's going to be a little more difficult
for us because we come with
different pieces. But what has been
true of this community is that
the children and students come first,
and their needs are paramount. It's not
about one student over another.
We have tried to help in this process.  That's
children first, the children of northeast
Austin, in east Austin, and all
of Austin.  I know it's something we're going to
continue today.  The other
piece is that I am an emotional person and
as many of us talk to students
about their feelings, we say that no
feeling is wrong, all feelings are valid.
So, if you come here today you are
worried, frustrated, sad, or
angry, all those feelings are
okay, you are welcome here.  What
matters, and what we tell our children, both
kids and adults, is how
we present those feelings.  When we
were talking about our experience and
our children, it can be difficult not to
pit one child against another child
or to tell them that it might be something that
hurts someone else.  What we've done
really well so far are our
conversations about how
we're sharing that.  Someone who
is listening wants their children to feel
safe in our community.  It is an
honor for us to be part of this
conversation.  I'm going to pass it on
to Miss Ali right now, who's also going to talk
about the rules.
My name is Ale Graduchi.  I am the
executive director of the
purpose of our
meeting, which the director already stated before, and I will
pass it on to our superintendent,
Matías Segura.  Our agenda.   We're going
to make it happen.  We're going
to welcome everyone.  Who's
coming, everyone?  We had a place to sit,
which is very nice.  So, we're going to
give you a summary, the proposal, the
changes, also how to mark anything
different from what you
received on Friday, and we're going
to answer the questions we received
in the comments on the cards. We
saw topics and there may be some
specific questions
that we heard many times.
So let's make sure we
answer that.  We can make an
exchange between those of us who are here
in person and those we have already received.
So let's take turns.  This is
how we are recording this meeting,
we are interpreting it
and she is recording in Spanish
the microphone so that we can share
this.  So we can call them
if we give them their microphones so that
we have the full experience for
our recording, and now we're going to talk
about the next steps.  So let's
talk about the rules we want to
build a future together, and see the
challenges.
and a solution that will make our district
stronger for years to come.  We want to
honor the fact
that we've allocated 90 minutes for this
meeting, so when we give the
microphone to different people, please make
an effort to keep your comments to one
minute and ensure that we can
maximize the number of people
speaking and the process, and
stay on agenda. We will
probably not
agree on some ideas, but
one thing we can
agree on is that we are creating this
for the entire Austin district, its
students, and honoring the space and the voice.
If you give the microphone in a timely manner, we will
follow up, but we will try not to
always put the same person on until
everyone has had a chance to speak if they
raised their hand.  We want to see solutions
and understandings,
and we want to embrace
transparency in everything.  and empathy, and I know these are
difficult conversations, and we want to
share compassion, clarity, and
honesty.  If you have a question that we did
n't answer well, you can ask
a follow-up question.  We want
all your questions
answered,
and the purpose of our meeting is to
answer the questions that
came up several times in the comments
and who is proposing in the
process, and we as management
want to give you additional information.
which can be included in the plan that
we will send out around November
20. And with this, I will pass it on to
our superintendent.  Let's look at the
context of why we're in this
process before we begin with the
comments, comment cards,
and questions and answers.
Okay.
So, I love
that this is Bridget's interpretation
of a circle, which is fantastic.  Thank you
for being here for the conversation.
I want to make sure that we're here, this is your
time, right?  I think it's important
before we begin to teach them how
we got here and why this is the plan we
have right now.  outline.
Things are very difficult right now, they are
very, very difficult for the
Austin district and public education.
And I would say that the board and I are
trying to find a way to
stabilize
and ensure that every student
can stay where they are.  That's why
we're talking about different schools
and their importance, and in the district we
have many families who don't believe that those in
their areas...
That's a problem.
That's a big problem for our
school district so we can continue
moving
forward.  So we hope to begin
this work.  Many things have been
a catalyst for us.  The first
is to recognize that we
have no budget challenges in
our system of records and no one
can help us.  The second thing is these
budgets, the
budget challenges,
the one we've had with
registration problems,
but the problem we've had with
government funds, I don't
like to talk about it, it's
not talked about much, but
the title was frozen this year.
things, millions and millions and millions of
dollars that we had for our
students.  That's the reality.
Many people on our
education teams were impacted by this
decision, and every time something like this happens to us,
I have to figure out how to
handle it,
how to protect
who we are as an organization.  and
make sure we
can help with the
students' needs.
But above all that, what we want to
do as a school system
, who we are, and what we believe.   Over
the past two years, we've had many
conversations about what we believe, and each
of those has impacted where we are
right now.  Eighteen months ago we had a
conversation
about
essential areas, conversations about
protecting librarians and
nurses.  There is always something that
we as a school and district
want, which is what is needed to
support our students.
We have to see that there will always be resources as long as there
are dollars, but we also
know that for us we believe that
this main idea
is the change is our educators in
the classroom.  When we had the pandemic,
we had a lot of vacancies in the schools; we did
n't have many
open principal positions,
and what made this worse was that the change
after change after change after
with the
district leadership, and we had to then
move the system around, and it was
n't looking good.  And they ask me,
Matías, challenge this, challenge that, what
they say goes and no, if we don't
respond, no matter how we
sit, we are in a position
where we have no control and we can't
do anything if we don't respond.  The other thing is
that we see
long-term solutions.  We are making sure that
we are identifying solutions
because we put people together,
we are the people and this plan has
several elements
so that they can understand
why this is and not that and
why
and why we considered that first
we wanted to have an alignment
throughout the district, they were not perfect.
Because we are a 24-year-old organization
.  Let me move to the middle
of the circle and our
borders were.
Then we
have built the districts and borders
and plans that we made.
segregation
and many things that informed how
those were formed.  What we know is that
certain experiences that each
student has in Austin, many can point to
lines and patterns,
and that's what happens when we don't have
seasons.
So we have the averages that go to three or four
high schools and another that goes to only
one high school.
Then yes, we will help with this.
We need to make a comprehensive change.
This is middle school.  These have to
align with those of the primary school.
So this is our first objective
.
Second, we wanted to talk about our
transfers.
We have political policies that we've had for
decades, and the reality is that
some of them
have brought about our system and
behaviors that I don't think
represent who we are now.  So
if we're going to think about that, we need to stay on top of things,
make plans, and make
changes.  And the third
is to include the monteori
in these elements
and plans.
The draft in the district.   I would say
, I certainly think we
want our students to have
access to programs in the district that
are unique to Austin, but we also want—it
may sound good, but if
we are not geographically
located or accessible—
when we think of the program that they
call wall-to-wall
, it
has the original intention.   All I'm
going to say is that,
yes, the hardest thing is to speak from a place of
understanding because it seems that
the topic of the classroom is very heated
and it's like an environment that isn't filled with
love, but everything we do requires
care, compensation for the teachers.
That's part of the budget, the
curriculum it requires,
which is millions and millions of dollars
each year in our curriculum
and I promise you there are
less expensive alternatives, but I'm
sure there are many communities near
the Austin community that don't follow our
curriculum to
the letter.
So, when we think about how we can
produce our costs as a
system, we start where we begin to
have losses.  For us, it represents
the number of entities we have in
our systems, in our schools.
It's something we need to look at in our
school system.
I had already mentioned it before,
in 1996 we had 96 schools
and in 2025 we have 116 and we have almost the
same number of students.  So there has
been an increase and a
decrease.  We have grown with the
city
and as families have been helped and
have migrated to Austin, but the
system has remained.  There is a way to
encompass all of this as a whole and
to see the adjustments we need to
make.  And lastly, it's because
we are here and talking about when
Montessori is the reality that we have a
responsibility as a school.
I hear people say that
our school has to stay, and an
example of what people say is that this
school has to stay, but no, this school is
much more than just 11th grade, one
year, grade number 11. What they mean
is, but not everyone
knows, especially when they're talking about the
level of 5,000, 10,000, or 20,000
people. The reality is that we,
the school district, are not responsible for
the risks as a function of
time
through the school years.
We, as a school district,
have to understand very well
the risks we have in order to control
them.
So everything is intertwined together.  It's not
a perfect plan.  No plan is
perfect, but I want you to know
that with the changes that have occurred and the
elements of the plan, we are trying to
cover all things at the same
time.  So, while we're
listening, we're taking notes.  I'm going to
share with you that we started
this process and I
strongly feel that the Monera school has to
be part of the academic system, that's why it's
included, but also
clarify other points
and the responsibility, etc., everything
else that it involves.
I believe I want to create spaces with
you to have conversations
with me and the team.  We have
questions that we have received and we are
happy to provide the answers
, but this is not the time.
Now I am very pleased to say that we
are making an adjustment
and we can, well, before we begin with
this, I would just like to mention
something.
Thanks to those who
attended the meeting we had
with the committee on Wednesday and the
conversations we've had, the
star exam and some of those
present here have created information resources
that we can include data so you can
better understand what we'll be
talking about.  From my
point of view, the starting point for
these conversations is the reality that the
system of responsibility itself
is very rigid.
There are ways to approach the
movement that can sometimes be a little
too fast in order to achieve your goal
as others do, like
the Austin school system,
the Austin district does it at a
slightly slower pace and let them
implement something, let the process run on its own
.  And when we listen to the
criticisms that have been made and have been
honest, it is that when we have
students who are mixed in the
classrooms, in the students of classes,
we have to make sure that there are
appropriate interventions
and know what they need
so that they can succeed in their
assessments or exams.  In fact, the
students are getting what they
need and what they require.
But who is at
Win School?  For example,
and processes are moving here.   There is
no doubt about that.  But what
remains, or does not remain, according to the
Austin school system?  The
Montessori system is not easily adapted; this does not
mean it shouldn't be implemented,
but we need to be very aware
and responsible,
and have the necessary resources to make it
successful.  Having said that
, it doesn't just depend on me, eh,
the Montessori school is one of 116 in
the Austin district.
It's something that a program that
is typically the focus of the bigger conversations we
have, but
sometimes we can review all that
work from these schools.
You also want to explain a little bit about what is being
proposed, what is being changed, well,
the draft plan and I think everyone already
knows, we are relocating some
schools and the Montessori schools to Go
Valley.  There are some questions that
we came up with in the meetings
and we've already put out a main draft that
you've already read.  This is this
specific move of this school.
Okay, sorry, but the microphone is
malfunctioning a bit.   It can be
heard without a microphone.
Okay, okay, I'll tell you again.
So, what this means is that
students who are assigned to
Win School will be reassigned
to Enders School and Hard Elementary
School.
Can someone turn down the microphone volume?
[laughs]
I thought it was the apple I was bringing
here, but oh well
,
because when the change happens we have to
resign the students if they go to that
resignation plan and all the
strategies that can be used.  There are
six in action, it's to
reduce, to be implemented.  We have two
options.
Once you
get to the third stage, which is the system
at the moment we are in, we have to
be accepted by the
school district and the district wrote the
system that we have a process and these
are the options we would have.
So for us it would be
reassignment, restarting,
or starting over with the
district verification.  And those are the three
options we had already explained to you
.  What we're doing is, I'm really sorry
about the microphone, but it
sounds really bad.   I'm
going to turn it off and on again to see if it
works.  No, it's the same.   I think it's
the horn that's
making noise.
While we're waiting, could you
introduce yourselves to each other in the audience and to
the person next to you,
say your names, and have a little bit of fun
chatting while
we fix the sound problem?
Thank you for your patience and thank you.
We had some technical difficulties, but it's
a very important conversation.  If it happens again
, we can talk
to our neighbors again.  But anyway
,
then
we talked about the original draft plan,
the plan we have and we want to
talk here about when we started this
work, as I told you before, it's
a three-month story and to give the
story, which is important, and to explain
the chain of responsibility that
brought us to this moment and we want to continue having
access to the programs.
And it has transparency and lets you see which
plans have been reviewed.  And
we're also trying to put the program in place, in
plans with the city, to prevent
other schools from closing.  And the
reason I say this is when we see
areas of the city that are experiencing a lot of
growth.  In other areas there are some
areas that are not developing and
we see this with the district, because the
programs have areas that do not have
enough seeds or that there need to be
more, sorry, not seeds,
available seats and we have to see where
the programs would be implemented and see how
the school works and why we have
chosen that strategy to
continue.
I spent many nights reading all your
emails and your information and comments,
and so there are other options if there are
things that can be considered.  And the
thing is, I want to think about it quite a bit. When you
have to introduce a new option, you have to put a
lot of energy and
thought into it to be able to put it into the
system, and when we pass it on to the board so
that they can
explore the opportunities and
start engaging with the communities
to see how the knowledge is shared and so that
people understand what plan,
what side we are coming from with this
information.  One thing I want to say
is that we are still trying to
find a solution.
How is this going to work?  I can't
say that we've reached the end,
the talks aren't over, and we're still
in the process.  There are some
more new ideas that have been brought to us, and
there are more questions about these ideas, and
we want to discuss them here and give them the time we
have.  I just want to
emphasize this point and we need to reinforce our
commitment to ensuring
that every student follows the program
and will have a seat available
wherever the program goes.
Just to make sure that's clear.
I have my questions when you're
ready.   It has to
be a dialogue, and this is going to
be a conversation.   Okay
, let's begin.
Okay, thanks.
The reason I want to start is that I
want to mention something that hasn't been
said and why we're here, but I
think many of these communities
want to mention these concepts,
that concept we have, that there is
much more
community participation.  One of the things we
've said is, there's a big difference, in
how the complete education plans are carried out
.  The complete
bilingual education program is for the certain
type of population that has to be
served,
that has to be in fact included
with the population that needs that
program.  And
that led us to you talking for
45 minutes about the Montessori program,
but there has never been any talk about the
students who need this program,
only the students who need the
Montessori program.  And I don't mean to
be hurtful or rude, but all of
us who have students at this
school
and who have been here for years feel
this lack immensely because genuinely not
once has any of these students
spoken about this option, and the
Wall to Wall program, which is the
complete education,
is like taking away the
student population, because if
you're going to
introduce some new,
functional students.  Part of what makes
the system work is that the
students in that system begin
working in the educational system
and do not participate in that small
Montessori instruction group.  That is why the
Montessori school
started this system from the beginning.
Therefore, moving this program away from
the community population would
affect it more than the
comprehensive education program that defines the
district.  At Montessori school, the
system is very good, and we are
moving out of the educational system,
and I've noticed it mostly in
northeast Austin.  Very good question,
very good comment.   This is something I need
to reflect on before
this meeting.
I read the emails and was thinking about
how those conversations came about.
This is all my fault because it's really
because my job here on
the board is to make sure every issue goes
according to plan.  And I have had
conversations based on my
interpretation of what I am seeing
with the board,
and we are very pressed for time with
these meetings,
but we have had many meetings, an
hour and a half, and I want to apologize
to all the students and
families so they don't think we are
leaving them out of the plan; that is not our
intention, and that is not why we are
here.  So, I'm sorry.  But as for
where the students are right now
, one of the things I want to
ask is, when you say that, do
you mean defined by demographic region
or is it I have the district map?
I have the map,
but where is your student currently located
?
All I want to do
is find out where the current students are right
now.
I currently read my emails and I am informed.   I sit down
and that's what I'm doing:
reading.  But
when we think about the
student population and where they are,
it's inconceivable that
the program could succeed in
another part of the city.  So I think
I do agree with what you're saying,
all the programs we have are
part
of the committee and we read and
study it and we have to think a lot about
how we're going to start a certain program,
but it's not
based on how you start it, not
always on the student population, the
size of the number of students
in that area.  We know where they live,
we know where the students
we need are, but we did it.  We don't
apply the same strategies for
some reason, and we always talk about how the
programs have to move and they have
moved.  That's the track record of the
Austin school district.  At some point that
was happening and is happening
throughout the entire Austin school district
.  Perhaps we
are approaching it this
way and not addressing the issue in any
other way.  It's different, but to
stay in this area
and I haven't read your emails,
it's something that can be explored and we
all have to take it into account.
One of the challenges we face is the number of
seats available per school.
I believe this is something we have to
explore, and there aren't many of us; we
always have to
see if these are the cases, the
challenges that we have to
see, because they won't see them in the same
way, and that's the truth.  But I appreciate
the feedback, and that's why we did it
this way.   I'm
going to take a question.
I want to understand the question.
Can you track it?
The question is, will schools in area
787 offer
three- and four-day full-day preschool programs?  Which
schools will accept students who
meet the requirements to receive
free tuition?
Thank you so much.
This is a great question.   I'm
going to share with you
from preschool to third grade.  We might
have a list of campuses
and I'm going to share that with you, Ali.
On October 31st we had a list of
all the
preinder campuses.  Third.  The PR3 one is more
challenging because we have classmates, and
in one of our
classmates after November 20th,
with all our
Pre-Kinder
3 classmates, we will be keeping an eye on how
things are going and the needs,
and to give them a little more Pre-Kindergarten.
three programs with them too.
So, please see the list of
those projected.
We did that on October 31st and they're going to
have the campuses right now.  And where
are those campuses right now?   They
will offer full-time pre-kinder
3, full-day or half-day classes.
For pre-kindergarten 3 we have to
consider
the program that is in the school that
was proposed, will they close it or
consolidate it?  We need to see who
our colleagues will be, those who
work the full day and those who work
half a day.  It's not that I don't want to answer
the question, it's that there's a process to
ensure that our
programs are where they should be and that they
start around noon, and to see if
our colleagues
can offer a full day, a
full day
before it's
presented.
Okay.  I want to clarify your question, which
basically,
if I understand correctly, when we come to or
we are going to have Montessori here in this
place, we are not starting from scratch or
moving it and starting
from scratch.
So, when we talk about starting from
scratch, the students, who are the
population that the students
here are, when we built
our plan with the idea of ​​having the
staff, the people, the resources, and
one of the things is to limit
disruptions in the best possible way
to have a healthy transition for
the students with the
community as well.  That's why
we're in this configuration,
dismantling or dividing.
Are you understanding what we're going through?  If
we are moving from one place, we
are not starting from a low point.
I'm going to say starting from scratch if we didn't
have a program in your school with
the resources, with the work we did
the first time.  That was starting from
scratch.  That's how I see it.  I
see it differently, but I understand what he
means.  I just wanted to
make sure.
Next, several people, families
will have access to transportation for their
children, and what will be the scope of the
transportation offered.
So, the Montessori program has
transportation.
It's one of the things we're going to
continue to stop.
If you
continue with this configuration, it will
remain the same.  We have families who
live very far away who come to
this school, and we hope that will
continue, which is why we ensure access.
And what if there's a change in how
we do that in our access right now
and preserve it, and how, depending on
where?  Give the student who needs
access to transportation,
then yes, there will be transportation.
If you are on Mount Sori.
I work here in the fourth and fifth
grade and I remember you.  My
concern is not necessarily where
the school is moving.  I
understand [laughs] it's
different, but I don't have children.  These are
the resources of Mount Sori.  I started in
elementary school, it was going to close, and they
asked us as teachers to give a
plan, and we gave them a plan, and the district
took us and we saw the Montessori schools,
and this is what we want to do, and the
way it was presented to us was that we
have the autonomy to create a
program and decide what direction it goes, and
then they told us that there was no support
from the district.  So, that's why my
understanding is what we're seeing
right now as resources.  I say all this
to
point out that we have a program, and it's a
program that requires much more staff,
and of course, if we're going to move to
another building and continue to have,
or rather, if we're going to have,
not enough staff—for example, we have
third,
fourth, and fifth grade, but we only have three
weeks, but we've had it for two months—and that
affected all the teaching, how can you see
the differences? And before that,
we had a classroom that didn't have a
teacher all year, so they didn't
learn anything, they didn't
grow.  Then we had
another situation last year where
the SL classes were in the same
situation.  So I came to this
school because Bridget asked me to
come.
I was going to stop teaching to do something
different, but I am very interested in
Montessori.  But my concern is that
we're moving to another building that's
a little newer and renovated, and we're going to
continue to see
the challenges of giving
students what they need, the resources we
have to share materials, and
so my concern is that the
district isn't doing that.  They have to
do it.  Montessori wouldn't be easy if
we didn't have more schools doing it,
would it?   So
I know that it's difficult to navigate
equal equity, equality.  We have to
give it to all the schools, but
the Montessori program requires more.
And if that happens, how do they plan to navigate this
so we don't end up moving to another
building?  But we don't have any female teachers.  I think
this is the first year that all
our classrooms are full.  There has been a
lot of growth in the last two
months in my opinion.  Because we've had
the staff,
but we haven't had this stability in
the last two years that I've been
here.  So it's difficult seeing that
Bridger does everything we do, well,
we can do, but always seeing them being
told no, we can't do
this, we can't do that.
So, it seems to me that I'm saying this
as a service, nothing more than people talking for the sake of
talking when they tell us to give the
options, the best ones to tell us the
best solutions.  I know you're
also fighting with the ASD, so I
wonder, what are the plans to
provide us with what
we need to be a successful
Montessori school and not just in name?
I can add a second part to what
José said.
We want more.
Uh, she says her kids did very
well on the state exam.
My name is Andy.   I
am,
if this is your question, it has to do with that of
my colleagues, and it is that I have been
here for a long time,
halfway through the Montessori transition
when Bridget came, it was a year that
we had special education
and
the
teachers had us
and we had the teacher's assistant, the
third, fourth and fifth everyone
left.
I've been through that and Bridget has been
very good at building this team.  I
'm looking at it from the point of view that
they're saying it sounds good for the
students and for the building that they're going to
put half of our
school in one building and offer the other
half to other new students.  And if they
then are going to have all our
staff moving, it will say that we only
have half of the Montessori
and our staff.  If all the
materials we have are moved,
we will only have half of the
materials.  So, my question is,
echo, given what my colleague said,
is it very expensive
to maintain a classroom?  It's thousands of
dollars, hundreds of thousands of dollars,
to the second half because they are
doubling our program, moving us
to several buildings or several campuses.
So, my question is, I understand the
time it might take to get
the teachers and this could grow and I
want to see what that process will look like,
but I'm also worried that I'll be
in a school where I can be in
my own classroom and I can see what's
going on in my world, but I don't have the
materials or I have to
share my materials with
three or four classrooms.  First of all, what a
great question! The first thing I would
say is that,
based on my initial answer, what I reflected
when Montessori 2223,
when Bridget came to do all the work, it wasn't that long ago
, it wasn't that long ago
, Bridget.  We were
learning,
[laughs]
excuse me,
this feels strange,
but we were learning.  The district
is learning, and that's the truth.  I would say I do
n't want to speak for Bridge,
but our school, our district
was trying to see and understand and how to
support this program and other programs as
well, other programs in the
district that haven't been supported in
the way we should have been,
and when I see it, well, we're
ready to have the program, but
I wasn't here at that time.  I know there were
many understandings and
school trips and we are thinking about
where we are on the 22nd, 23rd, 24th, 25th,
many superintendents, many
school leaders, many people coming in and
out of the system.  So, it doesn't
really surprise me that they have moved in a positive way
even with the conditions, many of which were
beyond our control, but we are
moving forward.  My goal is to
do fewer things and do them
better.  Right now we're doing it. We have
resources, we have support from the district,
and our board tells us, "Matías, it's a
lot. In some places, we're
doing things
because we've been
doing them, but there are things
we're going to promise to do,
and we're going to provide the resources.
In '22 and '23, when I started,
we had special education, and that began
the launch of the next two years and
the culture.
We had an imposed system. I desperately want to get
somewhere; I can't lose focus on
the important work after 23
years.
So I would say that if we move forward,
and the program we're
supporting, you'll have my
promises of success. I've spent
time here. I'm not as
specially educated as your director
or as you, but my role is to ensure that if we're
going to do something, we're going to do it
well. I have to make sure I have the
resources and the budget to do it,
but I can say right now that there are
things we can do in the district
to make sure we have and provide
answers for every program. We've always
done it because  Sometimes they come at us against
things we've done before,
but when we talk about
resetting programs—and I know it feels that
way sometimes—
operationally, and how we support the program,
yes, we have to reset the
district's strategies if it hasn't
been successful, how to support
our principals and the certification process, and
how we see our staff, how they
move through the process. This is the change
we made. This isn't about you; it's about
us. So, I'm not going to support
something we can't execute well
. The other thing I can say is, the
programs do cost more money. The
emergency programs cost more because
we have the language staff.
You can go to a school that looks
small
but has a lot of people on the street; it's not
because we're paying more in one
place, but because you made a
decision that that school needs
these programs and this staff. And
emergency language programs are like that; they're a very,
very high cost. But we
agree on that; we
agreed that this is what we're going to do.
If we do this, we're
going to do it the right way; we're
not going to do it haphazardly.
This is where we conduct
questionnaires
for families, asking about the available funds
and where those funds will go.
Before making a final decision, we need to know what's
important
to them. Our goal is to have as many
resources as possible before the
February registration period opens. We need to
review what
we offer in schools because we ca
n't promise
compensation. We need to know which students
will be in each school and how many will
enroll. We're going to
conduct a survey.
Okay, I'll continue with the
questions to gather more information
about where students
want to be and to answer what you
were asking earlier: how many
students are you expecting? We need to
understand how much funding we'll have.
We'll have a comment here
first
because more Montessori schools are being created
in areas that aren't currently
qualified.
We need to review all the
information in the system first. It's
not like something is already implemented in
the system and we know all the
materials and everything we need in
each school. We have to see what those materials
are, what
we need, and what
the...  Resources we have for each
different school.
I spoke with you last week, at the
last meeting you had,
and what we were discussing were
the therapies that will be
available at each school.
What are they? Well, we'll reiterate
the therapies we'll have at
each school, because we still need to
coordinate with the schools.
Well, if you couldn't hear me because
the microphone wasn't very close,
the bus doesn't work for
certain students who have certain
disabilities or who are in
certain therapies,
because some parents are
required to personally pick up
their children for three or four years old who are in
after-school programs or clubs,
and they're
sometimes literally waiting for their
parents to come and pick them up. That's
one of the points I have to
mention when you're having
sessions with the committee and having
discussions, and I saw the different options
for all the schools.
Ortega
is the closest, and Zavala is
the farthest,
in terms of the
services available.  district. That's why
these schools are less accessible
.
Another point I want to mention is that
there are people who want
educators and students to create
a symbiotic relationship, and that's what
makes Montessori schools
successful. Yes, we have three,
and we're so close to achieving it
, but I know that the
district doesn't care about that; they
only care about the ratings of the three
schools and this relocation to another
school. Even if they move all the
staff to the same school in a different
location, it's going to be the same problem, and they're just going to
move
all the people in this community to
another school. They haven't considered that the
people at the other school don't
want us there, and we don't want to go
there because we're used to the
northeast area of ​​Austin, and the problems of the
northeast are unique to this area. Every part
of the city has its own problems,
and things aren't similar.
At this school, there are many
brown, black, and white people with
special needs, and they wouldn't be well-received
elsewhere. Moving to another location
with a fraction of the number of
students...  I'm worried
that if a new school takes in
a fraction of our students, they'll be left behind
because they won't have the same
close relationship with the teachers they have
here. And that academic knowledge
won't be the same in both schools.
Another point I want to mention is that
Govali, if we go there to
Govali School, has 39% of its
students with special educational needs. My
child, who is in special education, and
other people here who have children with
special needs, have seen how many
resources
the school needs for the students to
succeed, right? In a million years. They're not
going to convince me that if we have the resources
here at this school, how are they going to be
able to provide resources for 39% of the
students with special educational needs
at another new school?
How can they prevent it from
succeeding? And the last thing I'm going to
say, I know I've gone on too long
with this question, but we've already spoken
with some of our neighboring schools
to see if they would consider
taking over.
Montessori children, if they could
retain more of our students there
and if they could receive our
staff. What do you think about that?
And could the Montessori students be received
here in the
nearby schools?
Thank you for sharing that.
I agree with you on some
points. We are at
the point now where
we need to have conversations
with other schools. I want to be honest
with the committee, with the board, and
what is all coming up
and knowing that not many people possibly
know, but I will do whatever is
required.
We have the best plan considering the
circumstances,
and now
the committee and the board
asked me to address new things. That's why
the Montessori schools have been
included,
and how we've had direct talks with those
communities about this issue,
specifically the Montessori program
moving not just as if it
were a random group. We're going
to do it by having conversations
and being able to listen to what
information has been passed on to us so we can support
the consensus.
I am very happy to have made progress
with the conversations we
've needed, and we are still bringing
up the issues in  The meetings are to
get the latest information, and
in other ways, how to implement
the plan
to secure the
necessary seats we need in other
schools, but that's a
separate issue.
That's why we're doing it
this way. I want to find the
best
way to give you the answers,
but we're going to continue having these
conversations, and that's why one of
the statements in the draft is that we
have the process open, and
we're still working on it. It's
already been mentioned that some of the
students,
in a couple of ways, have said, "Yes, the
students in general, but I'd like you to
consider this yourself."
If in 5 days, 100 years in the future,
the Montessori school is
functioning
because it has the
student population to maintain it.  And all the
students are fine and they don't have
Title One status so
that they can be experienced
Montessori students and succeed,
and they should have
avoided moving the students because
I know that new schools have been
built throughout the district
and it's part of the draft, but we also have to be
guided by the
guidelines of the draft that they have.  I want you to
think about
whether you can change this decision.
If it was successful in 5 years, it's because
those guidelines in the draft were changed
to modify and
increase the number of seats in
each school. Or are those
guidelines in the draft only for
this school?
Because I know students who don't
come to this school, and I know that's
part of the community.
The idea you say the idea that you
think says, well, you say that I
said, I thought, I didn't think.  Well,
well, this community has been thinking about
the last
conversations, not sharing with other
schools
that these people in other schools
are looking for brilliant things
or brilliant students, which is what is
beautiful and new.  And actually in this
community we have built something so that
you can work for this community
and with employees who have
a lot of experience, who are very, very
fluent in English.  I just want to
mention,
well, I've been coordinating with
other parents about something we've been
talking about.  That's all I want to say
.
If we look to the past and understand why
the plan was successful in the future, it's
because we can change the
draft guidelines, the directives.
I want to go back a little to this piece of
participation thinking
about what you just described in who,
who is Montessori.  This is a
very beautiful group of people who have
students.  That's a Title One school, and
most of the parents here
are people who... there aren't many people who couldn't
attend this meeting, and that's
something that worries me a lot
because for the parents who do have the
opportunity to participate, especially
for the Spanish-speaking parents, they
have no idea that this is
happening now.  So I want to
hear that he's doing the
district for those parents, not only so they do
n't know what's going on,
but so they actually have a voice and
can participate and help make a
decision, because this is very important
and
we have the privilege of
being here on a Monday and there are
many parents who are there,
possibly many families or
parents who are working because they
need to put food on the table.  on
the table in this situation and they are
terrified of not being able to have enough
money to provide food for their
family, but the bad thing is that they don't know
what is happening here today.  And it's
every family we
've spoken to that speaks
Spanish who doesn't even know the
school is closing, they don't know they
have certain opportunities, and I'm
very worried about how they're going to be
informed.  I've spoken with
some specialists and they haven't been
requesting resources from the district; they're
only giving some
people explanations
in Spanish, but that's a
huge gap. Why are there so many things happening, and if so
many people do
n't have information, why hasn't
the district done anything?  I would
love to hear from you if
any of you have any ideas or if you have
heard anything about this.
I am committed to
participation.  I will show up and
present myself at all the meetings.  This is a
very big effort and
someone has to be part of the
district.  We are here to see what
is available, and
when we come to these spaces, sometimes
early at night, sometimes
late at night, but we
come.   I ca
n't talk because there's a person there, or
at what time, whether it's 7 pm or
3 pm.  We have many things to do, and it's
very important that we have the presence
of the parents. There always have to be
people attending these meetings, and of
course, there are people who need to put
food on the table, as they say,
but we've handed out
comment cards, and we've told
people like you—well, there are
people who have no idea—but when it comes
to making decisions, and to be
honest,
there are things that aren't going to be possible.  It's
the honest truth.  It's not because Matías does
n't want to do it, it's that the challenges we
have in the system are
gigantic and if we don't point them out to us, I'm not
going to do it.
I'm not doing what I should be doing for
7,000 students.  I have to do it
as a complete whole.  I need to
sit down with you and do my best to
inform and be forwards and
backwards with the information, and that is to
participate in this type of community.
Please, if you have other ideas, you can
share them with us.
Ali is here with me.  I just think
we're committed to
participating and adjusting, and at any
moment it
feels like that's not happening, and you'd have to
tell us. But if
anyone wants something specific
where we haven't taken enough action,
if you tell me, "What about this? What about
this? What about this?"  I need to spend
more time looking at what our limits are
, because if we
fail it's because we didn't plan
properly.  The sequence of events
that occur is because there was a beginning
and an end.  I've seen that every time
we've made changes we've been successful, but
we have to participate, participate
because I know we won't be in the
same place in 5 months, but
also sometimes poor planning at the
beginning will hurt the
students, but if there's something that
needs us to
make changes, we have to
make the
necessary changes, but not only
commit to changing
things that are working.
Something Mr. Garcia mentioned that we did was
review all the
comment cards we received from all
the schools.
Some schools had very few
comments or none at all
,
so we tried to send more
direct text messages to them
so they could have the
HR codes to view the presentations
and promote the different
events we have.   We
already told the
school workers, counselors, and
family peace specialists to
look at the number of schools that have had
little participation, and if there are
schools that have had no
participation,
or almost always, the schools that have
few comments are the schools
where there will not be possible changes in
the future. But we have a large number
of responses in Spanish, and here the
interpretation team
translates the questions.  and we can
stay in touch.  We will continue
working and make sure we have
all the possible answers.
If you give me a second, there was a man
here and here and then here and here.  I'll
remember one at a time.
I have
you follow.
I can return to myself later.
First of all, many
disagree.
Thank you.  Let's be honest, there is
n't a school in a district in
Texas in the United States that doesn't have
problems. Right now we've had these
problems for a while,
and then I talked last week about
one of the things I said that weren't
very nice.  I read everything that comes
from the
four-school district where I work, and I
'm also
interested in all the information.
This has given me so much anxiety.  I
woke up suddenly in the middle of the night
and had an idea and I didn't, I have a
son who goes here in
pre-kindergarten,
but I have one who is 3 years old here and
then I see Blenden all day.
I hope I can go next year.
Blenden.  My idea is that we have
portables here.
Miss Bridget and Miss Williams, they have already
worked together on different
things, managing, coordinating,
sharing
resources.  It can also work if Wen
moves to the portables and Palm Springs
moves to the school, and when Palm
Springs is ready and they finish
building, we all move
to Palm Springs.  And the reason I thought
of this is because the parents say they have to
stay in this community
here.
Pecs is not that far away, much closer
to the other schools that have been
proposed.  They are also closing
schools.  So, that's just an idea I
had so we could move to portable
and they could move here, or they could move
here with us and change the name.
What we need to do to make this
work, and with Pecant Springs and the
students if they want to be part of the
program, those are some ideas I have, and
all of those are
things we can do.
I can tell you what would complicate that is
Win has three
free agents and also picks on springs.  So
what we're trying to do to move that
is to reassign campuses and have them have
a tap plan and try to break that.
I'm not saying there aren't creative ways to
change something, but it would be more of a
strategy,
assuming Pon was involved
in this movement.
One of the things I can say is that
because of how big the plan is, what
we're working on, different sizes,
there are different elements of the plan that we
have to go through step by step and that we've been
thinking about to make sure they
are successful and that we can demonstrate if we
have the opportunity.
But if Picon Springs doesn't have
the ratings it does, that would be
a much easier plan, not so
difficult.  And the interaction of there are
different scenarios.  I know I've
seen many of them, but I've seen one who
sees
this challenge
in the response to all these ideas that are
coming, because there are many ideas that have
come, but I want it to work,
but there are trusts and this is what we
can or cannot do because
we are taking this path or that
path.   It
helps you
and the assignment is there.
I'm going to come back here and then go
forward.
I am a father.
This is my neighborhood school.  Six
years ago we began consolidating
another consolidation.
I have a first grade and I'm leaving it in a
system where we can't plan for
middle school.  I've asked around and it doesn't
seem like they
have any strategic plans after
the conciliation, so what are they going to
do to prevent
the next
one?
I would say that I would say you say that it is
patterns.  I was here in '19 and
I saw a lot of that work and I
supervised it.  I am not saying this
is the most painful place I have ever been,
professionally and personally.
This is horrible.  I hate that
I'm the one who has to tell
them this information and be the
leader.  I don't want it for anyone.  I
desperately want to get to a
place where we are getting to a
sustainable place.  Everything has always been
urgent, urgent, urgent in 19 and
then the pandemic happened, then
everything changed.
Many people left, the
leadership changed, we didn't have any students, so for
the last two and a half years we haven't just been
working here. Well, we're moving forward,
moving the numbers,
the presentations we've been
giving in the last few months that we've
seen.  Our system is responding
and it's happening our way.
So, this can't be a pattern,
but I can't say it won't happen again
because I don't know what might happen at the
federal level, at the state level, and
right now we're having a
conversation about immigration
that's affecting us right now.  I have so
many different families who said
they decided not to come to the district
since around 2000. That's millions and
millions of dollars that
these students represented.
But what hurts the most is that those
students are still here, but
they are choosing not to come to school
because of the situation, and that's what hurts the
most.
I want to get to a place where we can
have more understanding and thoughts
about what is happening
academically,
being efficient, with staff so that
you as a parent, all the
parents in the district who will come out of
us when they are moving through the
program with their students, but we
agree on certain things,
but those are not our
community and our changes.
I desperately believe
that our reach is solid.  The 23rd,
24th, and 25th come every 5 months and
that affected us, and it's not a pattern.  I hope it's
not a forward one, but we
only attacked half of this plan
.  We're going to keep going,
we're going to be here again.  So,
my argument is that if we have the
resources, if the students receive what they
need, those students and those
schools
won't be in that problem because they
will have the resources and they will bring in
the families who come.  There are, many
families are making decisions,
you know how Austin works, but
there are some families who come and just
look at the grades and don't
want to go to those schools.
So our scope, our, I do
n't want it to be a trend, I
'm being honest with you.  So I'm going
to add a little bit of that, which is one of
our challenges when we have so many
schools.
For example, when we were
at Marshall, what does
each middle school offer?  That's a difficult
question to answer.  Right now there's a
standard we want to have in
middle school, in a small school,
but being able to get there is difficult, but it's hard to
fund such small classes.
So, one of the things we have to do is
move forward with learning
where we can define what we want to
offer and whether there are enough students
in each school to offer it and the
funds to achieve it.  I know it will
be much easier for
us to say I promise you that no
matter what.  These are the things we're going to
offer in elementary school, this in
middle school, and this in high school,
and there may be
additional things we can do, and this
process is going to help us, and with that
ability to communicate more clearly,
that's going to help us recapture
the families who didn't want to stay in
the district.
Hi,
I've been in
the Austin district, I
was a middle school teacher in elementary school and now I have a daughter in
Montessori
and I taught high school for about 10 or 11 years
.  This is my fourth year in
Austin Special Education District.  At a
time when there are many changes,
especially in special education, one
in the district,
I would say that I was never going to be a
teacher because of how it made me feel,
but here I am working
with students so that they don't have that
same feeling.  My question is, if the
district believes in Montessori,
wherever they are,
they need to have at the district level
a person with
Montessori experience and experience as a
Montessori school leader, not a
Texas public school, because that's not what we
are.  We are Montessori first and we need
someone at the district level to fight
for us.  We also need a
director
who knows what she's doing.
We have one, but she has... But if not, we can't
have anything else, a principal
from another public school who isn't going to
work.
Starting over.
My question is, when will you be able to
choose a new director for
these new campuses?  What can we do?
to help influence you to
consider a person who has
Montessori experience and leadership at the
campus and
district levels.
So, you graduated in the
district.  Can I ask you where you
went to MC?
Hand Park.  [laughs] I'm
going to give you something so you'll leave.
Remember me.
So,
one of the things I'm going to talk about is what
we can do to communicate with me.  You
're doing it.
I am certain that the leader of
this school, of our future school,
must have the knowledge
of Montessori and that model, and have the
experience and success.  And this isn't coming
from someone who's transitioning from
another primary.  I acknowledge this
as Bridget has done a
very good job here.   We
have no doubt, but if we
move forward, identify
these leaders as soon as
possible.  So we put this in place
in December; it's an effort to ensure that our
staff, who we want to
stay in the district, stay in the
Austin district.  So, once
we hire our directors and
understand why this
person is the right leader and we have
new staff, parents can know
before we're too far along in
the registration process, because waiting
until December or January or spring is not an option.
This is a very challenging thing for
us.  So, this is what we're going
to do.  If you have
any information you want to
send me, a copy of
our head of personnel, if there are other
things, requirements or knowledge
that you want us to consider, please, please
send this to us.  I don't do
anything without sending a lot of instructions, without spending a lot of
time figuring out what the best way is.
And if we can't find that person, we have
the ability to slow things down a bit
.  But I want you to know that the
reason we want to avoid that is to
make sure that people
know who the school leader is going to be
and make those
early decisions, whether people need to
be here or want another
experience in the district, and all of that is
completed before we offer any
positions outside the district.  Thank you for
sharing this, and you may
receive an email from me
, but this is a very large part
of our work.  We're already up to the
deadline.
I saw three
hands raised.  Nobody
listened so much that I don't even know if I have a
question anymore.   I'm
going to do it as quickly as possible.
Multros know me very well.
You said, you
told me a few weeks ago
that 45 students from here were going to
transfer, they
can transfer wherever they want.
So where are those 45
students from?
It is that strange little island
that comes from the edges we have on
the map.
I thought they were talking about another
place.
Here you can see that it's not moving back here
.  It's here too.
It's the yellow part, that area or those
families who live in that area that is
painted yellow,
something that I don't know if they are capturing,
what is important, this community
in them fought for this program
and this was happening at the same time.
We went to Dallas, we saw
a Christian Was elementary school which was
a Montessori elementary school and we had a
Montessori program and I have a
granddaughter here,
one of my
oldest.  My question, I think, is,
can children go to other schools,
transfer to other schools after
having been here for years in this
Montessori program?
How will the district help them
adapt to a traditional program?
And the other thing is more of a comment.
No, seriously,
how many surveys?
You
are still employed by the school.
I had
many surveys.  There's a survey
for everyone.  He thinks they're all going to
fill them up.  There are people who won't do it
because of some things they don't know how to
do, but they know.
So, these kinds of meetings are
important.  But my other question is
that I haven't seen an academic plan, how are you
going to support the students who have
been in the program
since third, fourth and fifth grade?
And how are you going to ensure that they
can adapt to a
traditional program?   I think I
had three
questions.  I think he's already got about five.
One more.  Another board said that the
board did not want him to talk about 50% of
the funds.  How are you right now?  What
number are they at the moment?   I
don't know where Catrina is.  I think that at
the end of the school year, more than 17% of us
are cutting, cutting, cutting throughout
the year.  That had a But also Miss
Bradley also, you also know,
we have a line of credit to
recover our cash funds
in the school year.
all together the income and everything and over the
course of the year we have had large
expenses during the year.  Then they went
down, down, down and during these
times in November we started to get
funds from the county from
property taxes.  what
is happening.  I don't want to alarm you,
but we're going to be very tight on
cash for credit, because of
what we're voting on right now, that has
caused all the property
and courts in the state of Texas, which is
how the funds are coming in.
So now those funds are coming in more
slowly.  So, we get
to 17%,
but we're still going to have to
borrow for 6 days
from the money that's coming late.
And that's where we are, and that's the
reality of how efficient it is, with
payroll and other
expenses totaling about 53 million dollars.  It's a large system, and
that cash flow and balance sheet—that can't
happen,
and we never want it to happen.  A
question about
We are creating
resources, those are the ones we are gathering
with the communities to be able to understand
each student and what their
school experience is.
And some will be at the school level
for programs that will go
student to student.
What are the best ways to get support
during the process?  It will be
reflected in the
school-to-school bridge team.
We will have, and I will hold everyone
responsible for maintaining,
monitoring,
and knowing what the guidelines and procedures are
for each location.
Theoretically,
well, that doesn't work if the community does
n't participate,
and in theory it sounds great, but it needs to be
put on paper.
Well, I've spoken to you before,
ma'am.
I do the work and I deliver the
results.  I'm not going to say something if I
know I haven't done it right before.   I ca
n't do anything without
community participation.
Yes, I believe in intentions, but we
also have to understand that the district
has had
a tendency to come up with these theories
that don't work, and they try to
implement them,
and only so that you know
that during the first month it's very good,
and in the end you realize that
the participating people have already left, and
when the people and the schools are
trying to implement the program, there is no
one to justify it, to
do it.
If this program remains open, it has to
be a program with
continuity, and that's what we have to keep
checking: that there is continuity.
Some of you can implement
things, but we have to keep in mind
that people have to keep it
open afterwards.
And that's what you're saying, it's something we have to
follow up on
at Goally School too, for
example,
Miss Montgomery had to
leave because we have a meeting.
Can I make a comment?
If it's related to the topic.  If it's about
participation.
translation translation
no no no no means understanding.
I think
you don't realize that translating that
stuff doesn't make people understand, and
that's why
Spanish-speaking families don't fill the
companies.  Yes, I am a
highly educated person, I speak 4 million languages ​​and it
has taken me a lot of work to
understand what is happening
and I think it is unfair.   I
want to say it in Spanish because it's my
language, but translation doesn't necessarily
mean understanding.  So the fact
that they only translate the
presentations and think that
people are going to participate
is also disrespectful to all
the participants because it takes a lot of
time for someone like me who is
very educated to understand what is going on
.   I
have to read the plans they
have on the screens three times to know what's going on
.
It's confusing.
They have a program that has involved a lot of
effort from the parent community,
from the entire school team, who are
all incredible.
You have a problem
making excuses.
We have a school, but it's
growing, it's participating, it's
a Montessori school, it's a
dual program, it's part of the community.  Why do
they want to destroy this?
How will that help
your long-term goal?  I had a
school that has not failed,
that
seriously serves equity
and the student population and the
community.  I don't understand everything you've
said, but I
agree with what you're saying,
that you're under a lot of pressure.
This administration is terrible.  I
understand,
but it's because we're doing the
wrong things that are destroying something
that works.
Just to answer
briefly,
we can always do better than that.
Honesty is key; we should
always do things right and there's always room
for improvement.
But we also need to be very
clear about the many schools
that are in a similar situation.
There are eight other schools going through
this,
and there are others where
all these seats have been
removed in schools, including
many almost half, and they have done
incredible things.
I know we're talking about
Montessori schools.  I just want you to know
what
other amazing things are happening in
schools
that have a similar history
and trajectory.
I just want to make sure of that
because it's difficult and we have 116
schools going through this.
Can you hear me?
I think I was waiting for what we
were going to come up with today
and we're going to have these ideas that we
've given you, but that's not where we are
right now.
That only further explains what we're
talking about.   We
already know that some schools are
having difficulties, but we all
have difficulties too.   Perhaps
some other school
that doesn't have problems, maybe
they want to team up with
us,
but sometimes things don't go that way
and we can, well, at least see this
idea in a constructive way.   I'm going to go over
the reasons why
we received funding, but I
only have something written here
for the elementary schools
in Jordan and Pick Springs
and the school in Sims
and the schools in Cas Garcias, all
these schools.  I just wanted to bring
this up so it's on record,
and the schools also have
unacceptable ratings,
and right now
the chap school is marked for me to
go to Andrews, and it could possibly
change, but only the chap school
also has a fixed timeline.
My question is, Andrews, if we are going to
or can we get
the fourth grade
this year and everyone gets a C grade
and move to FPR.  There is a
contingency plan in place so that all
elementary school students who
have the indicated closure plan can
be avoided.  It's
something we
've discussed with the
board,
and we don't know if it would be
an association against the school
according to the school district or
something else.  Typically, what would
happen is that if we didn't have these years
one after another after another, the first
graded, the second unacceptable,
we would have made a draft plan and
we can implement the plan in
the third year and be able to break the chain
of the three bad grades.  Everything
that happened with the lawsuits, which
we were part of, made it all the
worse.  So, one of the things we're
proposing for Doby,
while we're monitoring the
school year, if we don't see growth
or if we haven't seen anything
concerning that indicates they're going to get
a failing grade or
worse, then we can make
a decision
and enter into a contract, an agreement with
the school that wants to partner with us. This is
one of the two possible
solutions we have
before the fourth year, the fourth
grade. Someone could join
us to prevent this, but we have to
make a decision before they
pass, before they take the
STAR exam, because we have had
closures in the past,
and this has happened before. If
students got a
failing grade, they would immediately
close the school. So,
whatever happens, we have to make our
own plan before they take the
exams.  Storm.  These plans can be included,
they can include all these proposals,
yes,
but I have said to myself, we have not
expressed it in a larger open environment
, but I also know that
our community responds well to
this participation.
The way the agency accepts
things is how transformation plans work
.  There are many partners out there
offering very
good things, but they are looking for
very specific elements and skills.
So yes, the tools are
going to look different.   They would be
given time before taking
the Star exam. I don't know how
that will work, but it
depends on the schools.  So,
that increases the importance
of what happens with each school, the
primary schools in the
community, because two years ago,
if we had some schools that were
set to close, if they were successful
in the exams, especially at this
stage because there are more opportunities for
collaboration that I can help to
keep that school open.
and the idea of
continuing down that path
instead of closing it.  Yes,
gladly. I know it seems like a
long time ago
because it was Wednesday, Thursday,
and we had a very challenging weekend,
and we came back to do
this work and make progress this week.
We have many meetings pending
and we have some thoughts
floating around to implement them
in the last two school meetings we
had, but yes, we have had this
conversation.  If there is a school
nearby that would like to have
a conversation with us, I
would be happy to have it
, but I don't want it to happen.
What I don't want to happen is for them to
think that they are going to replace us or that
someone is going to replace us.  I understand your
concern,
your comment.  The last thing I'm going to say is
that if we're going to go to Govali, we'll
break the responsibility plan,
if we could
continue with the first main responsibility plan
and not assume that the problem is with the
new school.   We need to
see, we need to get
into the details of how the plan is going to
work, reassigning the schools
that are going to be closed
and starting school for the child in
another school.   That's
something I could potentially do. I would gladly
have those
conversations with the board
and see if there's a way to connect them and
talk.
I just want to see a little bit of talk
about responsibility.
What I told the comfort is that
while the children are arriving, we
can have some of these talks
, but we are responsible
if the response, if the communications
happen.
So we're going to have these people in
this room to have a
conversation and talk, and only have
a group of people participating,
people from the school who know the
school and who would possibly be
accepted and who wouldn't be accepted for
changes, and that would be the order.  But we
can do it.  I want to find out if
that's the solution.  I do want to
find the solution.
I will be working, but to
make your point, ma'am,
we need to have that conversation
with the school team and
the parents, and we can
do that.
I'm also doing this in
other schools for different reasons,
and
because we're already hearing children
outside screaming and we have
teachers who already have to go home.
Well, I have another comment
and I also want to thank
you for being here, for having these
conversations, and I thank everyone
who has come, and I
agree, I really
agree, that the district can't handle
all the students and the
changes that have been made to try to
solve the problem, and
ideas and
comments are welcome.  We are talking
because we have a shortage or
surplus of seats in the schools
and what are the dollar amounts
allocated by the district for the
schools.  But is
there any reason
why this school could
possibly be moved to a different location, a
temporary one?
Because of all the changes they've been
mentioning since last year,
schools like Pican
Springs could be another resource and
another possibility
for them to provide a home for
Montessori schools.
And apart from this, will there be any other
factor?
A quick answer.  The reason
swing spaces don't work is that they
are not designed like schools.  There are no
schools there.  So, we've spoken
with the commissioners
so we can provide them with a name, a
district number that gives them the
responsibility.  And I'll tell you, in my
experience
with ACC schools, they are not
allowed to have continuity in
Austin district schools.
If we have an open dialogue with
them
and ensure they have seats for
the students we can recruit,
perhaps the schools, swing spaces,
would be looking at it this way
because
school programs can always be changed.  in order to
accommodate the schools that come.   Well, I
appreciate the question,
but I commit to looking into
other schools and talking with them, and if they
have more conversations like these, I
'm open to having more conversations
and more discussions.
We need to have
community conversations to see what's
new.   We
only have knowledge of
our own community,
and that is why many of the
leaders in other districts are not from
this area.  But let's
see what we can come up with
.
Well, I have to have these
conversations sooner or later,
but we are willing to have them.
We just don't have time anymore,
we have a quick reminder.
This Thursday we have the board meeting
for the revised plan
and the final recommendations will be
presented to the board on
Thursday before the break.  We'll be
in touch; everyone knows how to
reach us.  Thank you
for your wonderful comments and ideas.
Thank you all for attending and coming
here.
and for being present.